solidarity
some of the best brains in britain are
angry and on the streets paralyzing
classes for more than a million students
across the country
but many of those same students are on
the picket line in solidarity with their
lecturers staff of 58 universities are
involved furious at sharp pension cuts
pay freezes and casual short-term
contracts that have left some academics
on the brink of poverty
there are people as you say doing phds
that's you know doing their doctorates
doing their original research and
thinking wow i'm just getting to this
pinnacle of my academic work it's taken
me 15 20 years whatever to get there and
suddenly smack in your face this idea
that you're going to be like an uber
driver you're landing up in this
casualized sector with potentially being
sacked at any point campaigners say
universities are hiding the full truth
from fee paying students
this is the dirty secret that keeps uk
higher education afloat people from all
around the world come to study in the uk
and pay
eye-watering amounts of money to do it
but the people who lead uk higher
education institutions would rather see
mass disruptive industrial action every
year then fix these basic problems
this is the voice of amy an english
lecturer
you know these universities are making a
lot of money off of students but they
are not
compensating their staff and staff are
having to live in really severely
insecure conditions she doesn't want to
appear on camera because she doesn't
want what happened to her to undermine
her future career whilst doing her
postgraduate degree and teaching at
london university she made fifteen
thousand dollars a year unable to pay
rent costs she chose to live in a tent
for two years and carry on teaching her
students never knew
there have been stories about casually
staff who've been facing homelessness um
definitely a lot of casual staff have
had the experience of not being able to
afford
uh rent and have had to couch surf or do
those kinds of things or they're
stretched between
multiple different
short
or hourly paid contracts
the average salary of a university vice
chancellor is 330 000 a year excluding
bonuses an average electoral salary
fifty thousand the university's uk that
represents the employers and the
pensions dispute denies there's a
problem we're not corporate uh
big business we're charities almost all
uk universities are charities and we
will try to reduce casualization
wherever we can but of course
some of the people that we employ
actually
want
casual jobs because they have careers
elsewhere
if the pandemic has taught us anything
is that people on short term contracts
with unpredictable hours with few
employment rights can quickly run into
trouble if their employers suddenly for
instance decide that their jobs are
expendable many of these lecturers
believe that they're being forced to
make a difficult choice between living
precariously or giving up the careers
they love
steve barker al jazeera london